vous parlez beaucoup des tweets mais moi
sauf à la présomption je veux bien le
croire sur sur le fait que ce n'était
pas lui mais on en est sûr la parodie
moi c'est ce qui me gêne la plus ces
attentats par six attentats par là
c'était il ya quelques mois il avait
donc plus de 18 ans était pas un gamin
mois il a expliqué la raison pour moi ça
me gêne énormément de banaliser de rire
là dessus et il a quand même son succès
face à victoire elle est beaucoup due
aussi à au message qu'il apportait à sa
personnalité
la différence au droit à la différence
tout ça c'était pas la comptabilité à la
vidéo à temps car si attentats par la
vue dans vidéo voilà qui était en fait
normalement une reprise de quelques vous
choisi neva rosiers et la lakers en jeu
chacun point de choquer et moi j'avoue
que moi ajouté par les twitts que je
rappelle aux gens s'ils ne reçoivent ces
nouveaux dégâts demande qui est la cause
des de la parodie justement absolument
c'est le sénateur henri leroy qu envoyé
une lettre aux membres du jury français
voilà pour le retirer à cause justement
de cette raison-là notamment détruit
fiables les tweets le crime contre
l'humanité vient de l'israël ça c'était
en 2014 et arrêtez de vous attaquer à
dieudonné vous ne le connaissez pas en
2014 et rappelle qu'on n'est pas sûr que
c'est lui qui les a très très gênant non
il doit pas représenter là je vais faire
court un nom il doit pas représenter
parce que dieudonné les tweets et la
parodie pour moi c'est trop mais neil
avait été éliminé de voice pour à peu
près les mêmes choses on voit pas
pourquoi elle avait reconnu avoir tweeté
elle sait qu'on va piquer cia l'échangé
cesser les codes avec d'autres personnes
et que d'autres personnes ont écrit sur
way ma façade je connais pas beaucoup de
gens qui donnent leur cote comme ça tout
le monde moi c'est une excuse ok il a
trouvé ça comme argument c'est son
problème mais franchement je suis projet
d'y croire alors d'autre que des
week-ends pourquoi qu'on peut dire quand
on va moi je n'ai jamais dit ça mais je
veux dire des fois les adolescents
voient là où ils sont baisse quoi ben tu
vois là c'est l'âge bête mais pourquoi
enseigner parachève son argument de
défense peut-être sa part commenté un
quatuor et 14 des conneries je suis
d'accord avec toi en fait si c'est lui
il
il aurait dû assumer en disant ben voilà
c'est m'excuser voilà si c'est lui je
m'excuse j'ai été bête voilà
le dire mais par contre il va y aller
mais ça va il sa forme à gueuler ma
gueule et on termine moi je suis pas
d'accord avec toi et non plus avec
myriam je pense que ça a pas forcément
mal se passer parce que connaissant bien
tel aviv et connaissant bien le contexte
là bas je pense qu'ils sont vraiment au
sud ça c'est la première ville qui
revendique la gay pride
quand même ils sont hyper ouvert et je
pense qu'au contraire ils vont
l'accueillir à bras ouverts pour lui
montrer qu'il est complètement à côté de
la plaque et c'est ça la plus jolie
enfin la plus belle victoria un sondage
donc regarder le sondage qui dit si on
vous a posé la question
bill à la ceni doit-il toujours
représenté la france à l'eurovision oui
à 54 % seulement moi je vous donne
rendez-vous en une seconde seulement
ma crainte je ne sais pas s'il a tué ou
pas présomption d'innocence si
évidemment c'est pas lui il a toute mon
affection
ma seule crainte c'est qu'effectivement
il peut avoir trente gardes du corps
quand il va atterrir là bas avec un
tweet comme ça contre l'israël si les
gens ne le crois pas j'ai qu'une crainte
c'est que ça se passe mal physiquement
pour lui qu'ils soient agressés c'est ma
seule crainte moi j'espère qu'il n'ira
pas à l'eurovision mais juste pour sa
vie parce que j'ai peur qu'ils soient
agressés là bas maintenant voilà longue
vie encore une fois on ne sait pas si
c'est lui ou pas